nachdem der Helikopter Drop auf ein
halbes Jahr ohne Probleme geplant und
geprobt wurde drohte dieser eine Nacht
vor Aussetzung aufgrund von
misskommunikation seitens des
helikopterunternehmens zu scheitern nur
dich Hartnäckigkeit und gemeinsame
Anstrengungen gelang es im Team dann
doch ein Kompromiss zu finden was jedoch
eine komplette Umstrukturierung der
Aussetzung bedeutet außerdem traf das
Team beim Aussetzen der Teilnehmer
dragex auf einheimische Fischer die sich
an Sabrina Spot ausruhen auch diesen
musste noch in der Vornacht klargemacht
werden hier nicht bleiben zu können in
dieser Folge zeigen wir euch was das
Erscheinen fremder Menschen für das
Projekt bedeutet und welche Maßnahmen
getroffen werden mussten um dies zu
verhindern wenn ihr auch in Zukunft
nicht verpassen wollt was hinter den
Kulissen von 7s world Staffel 2 passiert
und ihr uns unterstützen möchtet dann
abonniert diesen Kanal
[Musik]
die heutige Folge wird euch präsentiert
von Coro bei dem ihr dauerhaft mit dem
Code day 5% aufs gesamte Sortiment
sparen können vom Snacks wie diesen
veganen Haselnuss Crunchies über
Nussmischung bis hin zu getrockneten
Früchten gibt es so ziemlich alles was
Sie an Snacks für einen perfekten Server
stride haben braucht außerdem gibt es
eine Menge Zutaten um euer Frühstück
Mittag oder Abend essen aufzupeppen und
das beste Koro setzt auf Fähre und
nachhaltige Produktion auch für Sportler
gibt es Produkte wie dieses vegane
Proteinpulver es ist also wirklich für
jeden von euch in jedem
Anwendungsbereich irgendwas dabei und
eine Menge auf der Website zu finden
klickt jetzt auf den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung bestätigt eure Snacks
und spart dauerhaft mit dem Code Dave 5%
auf gesamte Sortiment vielen Dank an
Kurve für die Unterstützung und euch
viel Spaß mit dem Video
und jetzt kam
jetzt kam noch die die Meldung dass
Leute auf der Insel sind das ist das
eine Ding worauf wir keinen Einfluss
haben weil die Insel so groß ist das
unmögliches zu kontrollieren ob irgendwo
an irgendeiner Ecke irgendjemand an
landet im Worst Case rufen wir das
Militär
folgendes Problem also wir waren vorne
haben die ganzen Säcke rausgegeben da
waren mehrere Leute am Strand die da
eigentlich selten sein sollen und nach
Rücksprache mit dem Orga Team was quasi
jetzt noch in banana City ist äh fahren
jetzt Tom und ich noch mal zu dem Sport
hin und checken noch mal ob der Rucksack
wirklich noch vollständig ist und noch
da ist und gucken dass wir jeder
lassenschaften von denen beiseite räumen
können und das checken jetzt ab
das ist was davon wurde gewarnt von
anderen großen Produktion das Leute die
irgendwie davon erfahren haben dieses
Wissen nutzen um absichtlich ja Schaden
zu verursachen und dann Lösegeld
erpressen also so nach dem Motto pass
auf ich lege jetzt hier an mit meinem
kleinen Boot und wenn ich mich verpissen
soll dann kostet das 10 000
. yes
die Fischer waren zum Glück weg und auch
Sabrina Spray back war vollständig nach
all diesen lässt mir den Maßnahmen stand
im Drop auf jetzt also nichts mehr im
Wege zumindest dachten wir das
knossi Nova Otto Fritz mit mir max
mitkommen wir gehen jetzt zum roten
Helikopter
richtig nervös
[Musik]
okay wir hatten diesen ganzen Stress
gestern dieses Last Minute die komplette
Logistik umschmeißen das hat jetzt alles
geklappt jetzt sollten wir eigentlich
safe sein wir müssen nur noch hoch
fliegen die Teilnehmer rauswerfen und
dann haben was was könnte jetzt noch
schief gehen
und
oh shit
da sollten wir uns mal wieder ihren
alles klappte soweit wir sind über den
Dschungel geflogen die Aussicht war der
Hammer dann flogen wir die Küste entlang
und wir waren ganz im Norden und ich
gucke aus dem Fenster sie bei Sabrina
Spot einfach so eine komplette
fischertruppe die da auf dem Strand
abhängt
wirklich der Gedanke der mir dadurch den
Kopf ging war scheiße das war's auf
einmal knackt die hinter kommen ich weiß
einer der Koordinatoren im Medicopter
Johannes
aber auch schon richtig geschockt so
in dem wir gesprochen hat sondern und
ich sofort Wochen und Monate haben wir
hier abgefragt haben gesagt hey sagt
allen Fischer bescheid das sind offene
Gewässer also jeder darf hierhin kommen
das ist legal wir hatten zwei Stunden
bevor die Helikopter kam noch mal die
komplette Insel abgefahren um zu checken
dass ich wirklich auch keinen Fischer
keine Menschenseele sich irgendwo in
Nähe der Insel verloren hat und du
guckst aus dem Fenster und das ist
wirklich dein ultimativer Albtraum warum
das so problematisch ist hat mehrere
Gründe zum einen sollen die Teilnehmer
das Gefühl von 100 % remote bekommen und
das Gefühl isoliert auf einer einsame
Insel ausgesetzt zu sein angetrieben
alleine durch die eigene Willenskraft 7
Tage ohne Kontakt zu anderen Menschen
durchzuhalten fremde Menschen zerstören
diese Isolation außerdem wirkt das
Anlanden von fremden Menschen ein hohes
Sicherheitsrisiko in der Region finden
sich viele Menschen Schmuggler für die
geltendes Recht nicht sonderlich hoch im
Kurs steht in einem Worst Case Szenario
könnten diese einen ohnehin geschwächten
Teilnehmer überwältigen oder verletzen
ich wusste okay gut es gibt genau eine
Chance die wir haben und das ist wir
müssen das Rettungsboot was eigentlich
für Notfall vorgesehen war irgendwie
erreichen und dazu bewegen
schnellstmöglich zu diesem Spot zu
kommen und die Fischer Leute da
wegzubekommen bevor wir den Job auf da
machen
so wir hatten das Problem die Hacienda
und unsere emergency Boot war komplett
im Süden der Insel wir selber sind
gerade komplett in den Norden geflogen
und die Funkverbindung war so schlecht
also du konntest wirklich in 70% der
Insel keine Funkverbindung bekommen wir
waren soweit weg ich habe mir gedacht
okay gut wir haben keine Chance
aber ich probiere es einfach trotzdem
mal den Kanal umzustellen habe den
Funkspruch abgelassen ja Paddy an
zentral oder Boot könnt ihr mich hören
warten warten dann kam der Funkspruch
zentral am Paddy wir hören dich
und also ich war in meinem Leben noch
nie so eine andere Stimme zu hören
jeden Moment konnte die Funkverbindung
abbrechen und ich habe sogar noch diesen
Spruch rausgehauen ja Paddy ein zentrale
wir haben Fischer an dem Spot von
Sabrina ihr müsst schnellstmöglich dass
emergency Boot hochschicken schafft die
da weg
dann war der Kontakt auch schon auch
schon weg wir sind auch schon mehr
rausgeflogen wir mussten selber nicht
genau ob der ob das alles durchgegangen
ist ob das geklappt hat dass die
zentrale das Boot kontaktiert hat
dann kam schon das nächste Problem
nämlich das Thema Benzin und dann habe
ich halt abgefragt okay gut Jungs die
wie sieht's bei euch aus wie viel für
wie lange habt ihr noch Benzin so
stellte sich raus der zweite Teilnehmer
Helikopter wo der Johannes drin saß
hatte noch für eine Stunde 10 Minuten
Benzin damit das Boot vom Süden in den
Norden der Insel fährt und die Leute da
weg bewegt brauchen wir knapp eine
Stunde so und das hieß die allererste
Option ein bisschen Zeit hinten bisschen
was mehr fliegen über die Insel fliegen
Zeit gewinnen damit wir die die
Fischerboote da wegbekommen die war
schon mal vom Tisch unter okay Scheiße
es reicht nicht dass du ein Problem hast
jetzt kommt schon das nächste nee zurück
über die Insel und glücklicherweise kam
dann schon der Funkspruch rein ähm jo
Zentrale an Helikopter das Boot ist
unterwegs und dann mussten wir okay gut
das erste Problem vielleicht vielleicht
schaffen wir das das zu lösen aber wir
haben immer noch ein massiven Wettlauf
gegen die Zeit gerade und dann haben wir
gesagt okay gut bisschen was Ländern
jetzt die Reihenfolge wir fangen
weiterhin mit Joris dem ersten an machen
die Reihenfolge weiter überspringen
Sabrina fliegen dann irgendwo die Runde
zu Ende und hoffen dass wir am Ende noch
genug Benzin im Tank haben um zu Sabrina
rüber zu fliegen sie raus zu droppen und
zu BASE zurückzukehren wir waren schon
auf dem Weg zu Joris zu dem ersten Spot
und dann fiel mir plötzlich ein AH shit
unser safety Boot fährt wahrscheinlich
genau gerade von jorispott her da können
wir auch nicht den Job aufmachen das
heißt dann haben wir dann noch in aller
letzter Sekunde und wir waren vielleicht
so zwei 300 m vor seinem Sport haben wir
noch durchgegeben okay gut wir müssen
wieder den Plan ändern und
glücklicherweise hat die Kommunikation
mit Johannes und Martin super gut
geklappt wir haben das den Helikopter
Piloten super schnell kommuniziert alle
abgedreht Richtung Norden und sind dann
zum vierten Spot dem Spot von knossi
geflogen wie kann man den Spot an die
Koordinatoren saßen alle vorne und ich
weiß noch ich drehe mich um schau schau
Max an er schaut mich völlig in Geister
an hat von dem einen nichts mitbekommen
dachte wir hätten uns beim Sport
verflogen ich rufe nur so raus ja knossi
muss raus knossi ja ja knossi schmeiß
genoss hier raus knossi hat das wirklich
wortwörtlich was das Kotzen bekommen
weil er halt nicht damit gerechnet als
erster abgesetzt zu werden in dem Fall
war er dann der erste auch für uns
überraschend Max sagt das im knossi der
knossi guckt ihn einfach völlig
entgeistert an wie ich ne die hat
eigentlich kommuniziert bekommen dass
die am 4.7 Stelle waren und ja ich habe
es nicht gesehen aber er muss wohl in
dem ersten Moment wirklich keine bleich
sein kann wenn ich plötzlich gesagt
Video du musst jetzt aus dem Helikopter
springen
und dann sind wir die weiteren Spots
abgeflogen das hat dann alles
funktioniert und dann kamen wir kurz vor
Sabrinas Spot an da gab es dann wieder
eine Funkverbindung mit dem Boot und na
die Anzeige war so okay wir sind gleich
da wir haben jetzt auch nicht so viel
Zeit und die waren sie ja okay wir sind
auch gleich da wir brauchen noch fünf
Minuten und dann haben wir ja vor
Sabrina Spot noch gemacht dann haben wir
den Helikopter Piloten gesagt ja komm
dreht mal hier noch eine Runde um den
Dschungel und dann waren wir auch sehr
gut wir können jetzt auch nicht mehr
lange länger warten wir haben kein
Benzin mehr wir fliegen über den Berg zu
Sabrina Spot hören noch den Funkspruch
ja die Luft ist rein gucken und sehen in
der Ferne einfach nur noch dieses
Fischerboot was was da so weg hat oh
Gott ist und da allen ein Stein vom
Herzen gefallen und Sabrina konnte
einfach an ihren schönen remotenort
einspringen
[Musik]
was zum flying [ __ ] oh mein Gott
oh mein Gott
das kann keiner machen das was hier
gerade passiert ist kann keiner machen
der bei irgendeiner verfickten
TV-Produktion arbeitet und irgendwelche
scheiß Regeln einhalten muss es gibt
niemanden der irgendwas in die Richtung
machen kann im Fernsehen das hier ist
wirklich einsame Spitze es gibt nichts
Vergleichbares gar nichts
scheiße und was machen Scheiße hey wenn
die nicht abliefern jetzt die scheiß
Kandidaten ne
Aktion und jetzt noch also bessere
Schlaf Voraussetzung um der Held zu
werden hast du nicht wenn du aus dem
Scheiß hier kommt das sprichst also wir
hätten noch reinschauen
Alter war das Bild
ich glaube ich schon selten in meinem
Leben so unter Druck
danke ich danke dir für alles ich danke
dass es Dich gibt mein junge du bist der
beste du bist einfach der beste und dann
wirklich
halbe Minute nachdem sich alle in den
Armen lagen das erste mal wieder Wasser
getrunken hatten seit vier Stunden der
nächste Funkspruch wir haben weitere
Boote an der Küste jemand ich kann nicht
hören an welcher Buch sind die Boote
[Musik]
ich kann euch hören beim Clemens in
welcher Bucht sind die Boote
quasi auf dem Weg oder
den
zwei Busse finden
okay zentrale wenn ihr mich hören könnt
geh zu danke sagt dass sie irgendein
Security da raus schickt oder sonst was
ähm die müssen verschwinden und wir
merken okay das mit dem Fischerbooten
irgendwie ist hier ein Hörer Betrieb als
normalerweise das wird langsam zum
Problem man kann den Fischer natürlich
nicht übel nehmen sie dürfen sich frei
bewegen auf dem Gewässer und in Panama
ist es so dass Strände auch nicht privat
sind ja wir haben ja zwar die ganze
Insel angemietet aber jeder darf an die
Strände kommen und ja warum sollten sie
das nicht machen um eine kleine
Mittagspause zu machen oder abends
chillen und zwar zu dem Zeitpunkt ja
okay wir müssen jetzt schnellstmöglich
hier eine dauerhafte Lösung finden
heißt wir hatten verschiedene Optionen
die ist geil dann zu evaluieren zu
gucken was es wirklich sinnvoll also zum
Beispiel scheiden jetzt das Militär
sofort ein wo Du nicht weißt was macht
das Militär
schadet das Militär dann Invasion auf
die Insel und wirklich Schützengräben an
weil ich sage okay wir müssen jetzt hier
die Insel freihalten deswegen haben wir
uns nachts zusammengesetzt und noch eine
Lösung zu suchen und dieser dann so aus
dass wir mit zwei Booten Patrouille
gefahren sind wir sind an einen
strategischen Ort in den Norden gefahren
von dort konnten wir dann wirklich beide
Küsten gut absuchen und ähm Notfall dann
auch noch Unterstützung anfordern und
genau dieses Schichtsystem haben wir
dann auch strikt durchgezogen sollten
sich den teilnehmerspots Fischer oder
andere Boote nähern haben wir eben klar
gemacht dass wir hier produzieren und
sie gebeten das Gebiet zu verlassen das
wurde dann mal mehr und mal weniger gut
akzeptiert
der Rico war einmal mit dem Boot
unterwegs er hat da so eine Art kam
irgendwo
von der Küste wegbekommen der Typ fand
das gar nicht so witzig und hat dann
versucht ricos Brot zu haben also das
war richtige Greenpeace action.de
gespielt
können
riesenbrot angefahren
dann genauso zu unser Kapitän hat
Funksprüche rausgegeben dass er abwenden
soll die einfach straight weiter wurden
wahrscheinlich auf die Insel fahren und
danach Funkverkehr hin und her fängt das
wo dann zum runden fährt genauer auf uns
zu seitlich wollte uns wahrscheinlich
irgendwie
im letzten Moment ausgewichen noch
etliche Punkt wo ich hinterher wir haben
die angeleuchtet 20 30 Leute waren an
Bord das sind irgendwann gefahren ich
weiß nicht ob man mit der Militär mit
der See Polizei gedroht haben
krass aber mit einem Boot das wir
abgestellt haben das oben Patrouille
fährt mit Drohnen mit die wir teilweise
am steigen lassen um auf die Meere zu
schauen ob sich jemand der Insel nähert
und eben der viel zumindest darin eines
Landes und dem Minister eines Landes die
sich für uns eingesetzt haben das war
halt wirklich das Maximum was wir machen
konnten um remoten zu gewähren
[Musik]